in this capsule we see
definitions related to the process of
marco decision well then start
firstly to define what is
that a decision process marks well
which is called in English mark up of this
gene process or so despite a
decision process mark returns that's
four things first one set
convinced states where we define
often in addition an initial state to those
that's also a set of actions
action community did action is going to be
a function that will take at the entrance
a possible state
is going to belong to big is
our set of states and therefore action s
is a function that returns if I
find out what the actions are
possible that I can take how
that my agent can take kind then
a transition model then expresses
knowing s is to or must belong to
possible actions in the state s
when I use so small instead of
the action for to say the same thing
so actions like that it's the same
thing that they on the small screen so pds
premium knowing st1 it's going to be the
probability that I am in the state s
bonus if I am the state s is that I
do the action so that's what I'm going
call my transition model and
finally kind of a function of
rewards air de s who tells me what
is the utility of finding myself in the state s
what is the use for money
to be in the state and therefore in fact a debit
on a general model for a
stochastic environment in which
an agent to make decisions and
receives rewards one can
actually modeled
any environment
stochastic where there is an agent who can
make decisions so we make a
first guess keynes provision
marc collienne of the first order
to say that and so we see the assumption
here in the transition model
so we assume that if I know in what
state I am and that I determine a
action to take
that's all it takes for me to
determine the probability of the state where I
could be found at the next moment
minds so it does not depend on the pond
where I was at 8 pm under two
instances or three years was working these
institutes so that's an assumption
marco come we do in this
context and so for a process of
decision mark good care appropriate
we must be satisfied with what we
believes that its provisions
can make it not too bad
in the context of our application in
more
we could use a process of
mark decision comes back that will require
that we describe the goal to athens to
from a reward function
so if we want to model a swimmer
that we want to see act intelligently in
a given environment and then reach a
certain goal like winning result a
poison or won a game in a game
or a website in this case also it goes
we need to describe this goal
there in the form of a function of
rewards
a typical way of doing things is
simply high rewards partner
to a state that matches winning a game
or solve not so we put a mdp
a rat as a decision of process vote
appropriate help if the purpose that I
wishes to describe can be described under
the form of a reward function
so if we take the example of the grid
where we have a robot agent that can
move but when if the whole s & d
is impossible it would be all of
possible positions in the grid so
all the cars they identify here
will have some examples to identify this
would be all of his
positions when possible
it's about the stock equities of m
that would be the possible actions by
example if I was here I prefer
the four actions go up to
the carry she hung at 3 if I got
found here I could not
allow in the right because of the wall
right next so manage a whole
of actions that would only contain
three possible actions would be
returned simon steps correspond to
this winery the uci and then finally ben
may the reward function air de s is
described in this secular rectangle if I
find me a state that matches game
white
rds 0.6 to find a square like that
it would be less 0.4 and then for goal
for the few and to associate it with
where I want my agency to
places I had a positive reward
and finally it was mentioned that
effects of the shares was uncertain so
in this case it did that
represent by my transition model
so in this example if if I find myself
in this grid there and that I took
the action go room
so that would be the value of 'then is
that would be where they stand because they are
found in my grid and well 25% this
would be the probability that s prime is
equal to because we have it here 50% this
that then we would have 25% by the tpo 7 is
also and then for the other steps
passive to know be here ben I would have
a priority expressed in this respect to this
state if equal to zero 6 aces corresponds to
7 sits and that corresponds to the action
was going south
another important concept is that
from a decision to a decision this is the
choosing an action for a given state
so it's a kind of estate rules
vein action one has an example here of
the illustration of a mbp where we have
actions that correspond to
coordinates ex y different boxes
possible and then what we have a
tag for each of the links that
corresponds to a possible action by
example for if I'm in this state
if the action w that is the west action
with a driving range 0.2 it will make me
go from 21 21 to 20 13 0.32 May 21 from
21 21 to 21 13 then with 0.5 21 forgiveness
not 21 21 May 21 12
vervins doubt so we notice what
is the most likely it is
actually to move directly
towards the west but that there is some
quality that I do not make investments
direct to the west
because I have notion of uncertainty in
the result of actions age and at
arrows that are rather labeled by s
it would be for the action kids alpine
so locates a decision so that would be so
an example it would be for example that if
I find myself in 21 12 I do the action
west so that would mean that according to
this decision there if I'm in
this vise so badly the distributions that the
distribution that interests me is the one
given by the action where is our
different decision that would mean that
if I'm in 21 12 I want the action
taken so be it that corresponds to
east to east what could be discreet
in this example if but it's another
example of possible action now a
plan
it's a strategy that will determine the
choice of an action for all states
of big s so sometimes I will use
the word full sometimes I used the word
political these two words that are
used to describe the same thing so
if it's exactly I'm referring
will have exactly the same concept is
so a plan or a policy that's
really a set of these rules and
free state vein action so we could
as well as on a plane we often use
the symbol pis to represent
plans you will be brought a set of
decisions in what if in this plan there
if I find myself in 21 12
I should take the action wes if I
found in twenty thirteen should take
the action is what you find me in 21 13
my agent will take action titled
and so stood out here in my
example of rdp
where the actions the decisions that
would be taken by this policy then
1 are shown in dashed lines here
Sunday around 21 12
I take west action so it wants
to say that of this state if I try
probability the demand to these three states
following there and if I was in
twenty eleven is not the industry here
but if I had a lot like 20-11 as
that and then I had association the
decision of the action not shown here
then because some qualities come up to
other states next and here we have a
another example of plans that is called
peter so in this case also the decision
in 21 12 is different it's rather
action is what is taken
then in vain to the action that is
pressed is so we see that it is
well life these transitions the water are
indicated dotted here a plan or a
politics it's just a whole
decisions that determines all
actions that I should take for all
the possible states as a whole
of states of my mbp and so we will note
often pi 2 aces committing action
designated by my clan and if I'm in
the state is this so an algorithm that
run ray or would apply a plan
what they would do is
for as long as
I'm waiting for the end too, no hunger
the execution of the money so when if
I'll have a sailing loop that would finish
never will I do that at each
iteration game
I measured what is my current state
in my environment
that's the part of s for my state's I
ask my plan that she should
to be the action I have to take who wants
put back i'm going to noted hadopi
2 is equal to the action in question and I
will execute the action and then I will
1st measure what is now my state
ask for my action again given the
plan i'm running pi and run this
action and continue like that so
infinitely or until I have a
stop condition that I can
determined but generally speaking we
pose in fact another age hours
runs infinitely so where one
can simulate the shot he would run
without knowing when hunger to live and in
so does step 1 could involve
some detection so that the call
to censors could do why
maybe locate the agent in his
environment and the result so the state
following after performing an action to
your stochastic heads it's not
something we can predict
for sure because I a month
mdp I have a transition model that is
probabilistic so I have probabilities
associated with what will be the next state is
this crime which expresses that is the
next next value of s after
have performed the action a kind
several different parity kind not
necessarily to take advantage of 1 for a
alone and then following elections so that's
really transitions that are going to be
stochastic for the actions that I
will finally take in a mdp
if I specify a plan many countries
finally for a fixed shot will result
in a brand chain actually if
I know a plan ppi given its
state it means that s
my action here is going to be a function
deterministic of my state s
so in fact it's like I have a
markov chain which determines the
probabilities of going to express myself
so given is this so eventually it's
as if the balls of the transitions
costs of food only 2 aces
since then and give me my action
as well as it's not something that
that I can vary something that who
will be fixed if I suppose that the implant
data and therefore sets for a policy
who gives and I get a chain of
markov and if I go to rimont plan in
do the same policy
I'm going to have a markov chain that
vote is different and it's a chain
of markov of first order since that
depends only on the previous state
so there the state according to its distribution
departure only from the previous state and
normalize the states further in
the story